bonjour et bienvenue dans génération
europe avec les étudiants européens qui
sont derrière moi bien nous sommes ici à
la cité internationale universitaire au
collège encore britannique et nous
allons recevoir dans un instant notre
invité qui et clémentine autain qui
front de gauche nous allons parler
ensemble de l'europe avec cette question
est-ce que c'est l'europe sociale qui va
sauver l'europe
on en parle tout de suite
bonjour à tous d'emblée j'ai envie de
vous demander quand on parle de rose
sociale en quoi ça fait écho pour vous
quel sens savent le social par exemple
pour toi meriem qui espagnol pour nous
en espagne en a deux coups univision à
la française ça veut dire on est ont
fait rapport par rapport à l'éducation
les travail la santé et touffah
l'ensemble qui est on est en train de
perdre alors voilà c'est plus le
sentiment de scoop air mais c'est un
regard global james pour toi la priorité
c'est quoi quand on parle du social
faire en sorte que la politique sociale
et responsable que on dépense pas trop
on a un programme d'austérité que le
gouvernement a mis en oeuvre depuis
l'élection de david cameron en 2010
c'est très important je pense que
l'austérité dans sa lutte et oui c'est
plus la perspective dans laquelle tu
t'inscris organes qu'elle est quelle est
ta lecture justement en tant qu'allemand
oui pour moi oui c'est une europe
sociale c'est utile mais premièrement je
crois que il faut renforcer l'économie
pour créer d'emplois et tout ça parce
que pour moi un europe sociale c'est
aussi avoir son travail pour avoir une
vie bonne foi donc forcément on lit le
social et l'économique on y reviendra
yoanna quand on parle du social par
exemple qui roumaine
c'est quoi c'est la santé ces abats
l'éducation si c'est la mairie au
système social c'est tout
c'est dans un morceau ça englober tous
qui a santé éducation chômage retraite à
chez nous on a eu des politiques
d'austérité et on a dû réduire beaucoup
beaucoup de fonctions au public les
retraites pareil et ça marche pas très
bien
anthony laup quand tu entends par
exemple magna qui roumaine ou yoga qui
allemands alors que dans les pays on
voit bien dans chaque pays les réalités
sont bien différentes et pourtant les
discours sont les mêmes est-ce que du
coup tu sens qu'il ya une mentalité
commune sur l'europe où tu vois tu
perçois meurtre elle était comme uhnwi
si je la vois ça me fait rire le fait
que yoann qui est allemande parle de
besoin du travail moi que je suis
italien dans notre pays le problème
c'est vraiment le travail donc le fait
que dans toute l'europe on a l'idée de
besoin de travail
c'est ce normal mais le fait vraiment
que je pense que dans certains pays il
est un problème vraiment grave comme par
exemple en italie
quand on parle de socialement je pense
par exemple à l'université qui devrait
préparer le travail par contre en italie
il ne fait absolument pas on n'a pas de
retraite les impôts augmentent toujours
plus et de qualité même une idée d'état
providence
en italie c'est plutôt une peur on a eu
un dernier gouvernement technique qui a
cherché en tout cas de sauver l'italie
de déficit mais on a vraiment peur d'eux
de tout ça turenne de mon point de vue
c'est plutôt une conception culturelle
qui est différente de l'état providence
donc il est évident que les anglais
n'aspire pas vraiment la même chose que
les français c'est pour ça qu'on a des
modèles différents et les anglais se
retrouvent souvent que les français sont
des assistés alors que nous on trouve
que c'est le far-west là bas et ça
s'explique par bats pas des différences
culturelles
enfin ouais c'est pour ça que tu épouses
en france m chaque pays a sa propre
conception de ce que c'est le niveau
d'égalité sociale qu'on va attendre et
c'est pour ça que je trouve que ce
serait difficile de d'unifier les
programmes sociaux au sein de l'europe
alors on va continuer à parler de cette
question d'harmonisation signifier ses
programmes sociaux dont tu parles
simplement on va revenir à l'essentiel
tout de suite aux fondamentaux grâce au
sujet de thierry scharff qui est mise en
image par hugo nicolas quelle est la
place du social dans la façon dont
l'europe se construit depuis un demi
siècle
regardez c'est l'essentiel mons ou
social était plus présente dans l'esprit
des fondateurs de l'europe en 1957 qui
pensaient que le progrès économique
engendre est forcément le progrès social
et pourtant au fil des années et des
traités plus de 200 textes régissant
aujourd'hui les droits sociaux européens
outre les politiques menées en matière
d'éducation de logement social de lutte
contre la pauvreté ou de santé on peut
retenir trois domaines privilégiés
premièrement la libre circulation des
travailleurs
la création du marché unique en 1974 a
entraîné la reconnaissance des
qualifications professionnelles et la
coordination des régimes de sécurité
sociale
deuxièmement le droit du travail
l'intervention de l'union européenne
dans ce domaine est orienté dans deux
directions les conditions de travail
d'une part et une information et la
consultation des travailleurs d'autre
part l'union a également mis en place un
acquis considérable en matière de santé
et de sécurité au travail
troisièmement la lutte contre les
discriminations après s'être d'abord
intéressé à la question des inégalités
hommes femmes la législation
communautaire depuis le traité
d'amsterdam s'applique aussi aux
discriminations fondées sur l'origine
ethnique la religion les convictions
le handicap l'âge ou l'orientation
sexuelle pour mettre en oeuvre sa
politique sociale l'europe cdt de moyens
financiers non négligeables comme par
exemple le fonds social européen
76 milliards d'euros pour la période
2007-2013 l'europe sociale n'est donc
pas inexistante mais elle se heurte à
deux difficultés majeures
l'harmonisation des politiques sociales
des états membres et ses compétences
limitées en la matière puisque ce sont
les états qui garde la main sur leur
système social
oui donc on voit dans le sujet de
thierry scharff qu'il ya 76 milliards
d'euros du fonds social européen qui ont
été consacrés en six ans à l'europe
sociale ça représente à peu près 10% du
budget global
oui ça veut dire que la préoccupation
est là selon toi mais c'est un chiffre
qui a peu abstrait parce que 10% du
budget global si on prend le fait que le
budget global de l'europe c'est 1% du
pib européen
ça fait 1 100e en fait c'est très peu et
65 milliard sur 6 sur 6 ans et très peu
quand on connaît les inégalités qui en
europe donc à mon avis est assez
trompeur et que l'europe elle-même se
justifie en disant que des pur sang
c'est beaucoup surtout qu'il ya des
frais qui sont pas ajustable sur le
budget européen enfin une partie des
masses est importante mais dans l'absolu
c'est même plutôt assez peu et moi il me
semble que ce qui ressortait de nos
discussions c'est que même s'il ya des
divergences de conception l'objectif
c'est tout même de d'améliorer la vie en
fait l'objectif social et c'est pas avec
76 milliard six ans qu'on améliore la
vie
on va continuer à parler chiffres et
modalités de moyens de comment 2
pourquoi et de si ça marche tout de
suite en accueillant notre invité
clémentine autain qui est porte-parole
dansant qui est une déformation du flanc
gauche
bonjour à tous à tout
je vous demandait de réagir à ce que ce
que vous avez entendu déjà il ya quelque
chose qui vous a marqué oui il y avait
des remarques sur peut-être les
différentes traditions des pays
je sais pas si c'est tout à fait
culturel en tout cas il ya des histoires
sociales et politiques qui sont
différentes et qui peuvent expliquer les
évolutions du droit au maintien
d'égalité de liberté
voilà qui peuvent différer d'un pays à
l'autre et c'est surtout le sujet qui
m'a interrogé m à quel niveau
oh pas mal parce que il ya une
valorisation la de ce qu'est le bilan de
l'union européenne que je que je ne
partage pas on va commencer par la fin
mai les 76 milliards pour le budget
social c'est juste une plaisanterie
l'augmentation est très faible en
réalité c'était 73 milliards pour l'ue
précédent donc ça fait trois petits
milliards de plus qui correspondent à
peine à ce qu'est le coût de l'inflation
donc en réalité il n'y a pas
d'augmentation et ce fonds social
européen et les dédier à quoi a donné
des subventions pour par exemple un pôle
emploi une collectivité locale des ong
ou même parfois des entreprises qui
présentent des projets européens
donc c'est une conception du social qui
est plus de l'ordre de la de la charité
de la subvention à des projets mais qui
n'est pas une conception de ce que doit
être un rct qui permet de développer
je vais prendre un mot savant que j'aime
bien qui s'appelle les capabilités ces
parcelles mais c'est vrai qu'ils étaient
un prix nobel
un prix nobel d'économie et la
capabilité ça rejoint un peu ce qu'avait
dit l'un d'entre vous c'est le droit à
la santé à l'éducation à ses devoirs
comme dans tous ses droits fondamentaux
qui nous permettent d'être libre parce
que la liberté véritable c'est d'avoir
les conditions de pouvoir l'exercer mais
clémentine autain est ce que le social
doit leur à seebach the rope
oui parce que c'est passé par le sais
quoi dans cette échelle là ça pourrait
au de l'état quel est le sens de
l'europe si c'est pas pour améliorer les
conditions de vie des européens
moi je ne comprends pas or on a pris les
choses à l'envers on a commencé pour
construire cette europe par faire un
grand marché et depuis ça ne cesse
d'aller dans ce sens là et le fonds
social il illustre ça vous savez que par
exemple dans ce fonds social il ya
quatre milliards qui ont été données
pour l'emploi des jeunes
d'accord ça c'est en 2013 l'année
dernière petit super 4 milliards pour
l'emploi des jeunes savez combien
étaient donnés aux banques au moment de
la crise des subprimes ce nom mais il ya
beaucoup de jeunes dans les longueurs
sur lien familial aubry y est on est on
est dans des épures qui n'ont
littéralement qui en avoir quatre
milliards d'un côté 100 milliards de
l'autre surtout on voit bien les
différences d'échelle
alors on va donner la parole à lorraine
pour qu'elles puissent réagir à ce que
vous dites là ok ben je suis juste
d'accord avec vous dans le sens où l'on
espère tous que l'europe pour nous
améliorer notre vie quotidienne
mais après vous parlez de des sommes qui
ont été versés etc
mais il faut quand même pas oublier
qu'on n'est pas un état fédéral et donc
plus coup on peut pas espérer d'un
organe européen de verser tout cet
argent
et s'il n'y a pas eu d'augmentation dans
ces versements c'est aussi parce que
enfin il faut pas se lier il faut pas
nier on est en crise et du coup enfin on
ezeiza rogne de tous les côtés je pense
que c'est plutôt positif justement que
ça n'est pas baissé parce que justement
d'un point de vue national on est
toujours en train de se plaindre parce
que les aides baisse a la preuve qu'au
niveau européen ce n'est pas le cas mais
la question sociale c'est pas une
histoire de petites enveloppes dead pour
le soutien comme je disais tout à
l'heure sur une logique de charité ou de
subventions la question sociale c'est
une question de droit donc par exemple
est ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui des droits
qui ont été harmonisés et qui permettent
aux européens de mieux vivre
yoanna qu'en tu entend tout ce que tu as
l'impression que justement une
harmonisation européenne serait possible
ou les réalités sont trop différentes
selon ce qu'on vit en roumanie en
allemagne
c'est exactement ça les disparités les
discret pense des niveaux
socioéconomiques dents au sein de
l'union européenne entre les pays sans
gigantisme
on n'a pas par exemple le smic en
roumanie sont environ 300 euros
bien sûr tant qu en france 1400 oui ok
comment est ce qu'on pourra faire une
harmonisation manque premièrement
commencer par la coordination des
politiques sociales
on pourrait créer une sorte de contrat
de travail européen
on voit tous on est là dans la mobilité
en travail deux ans en france ce
peut-être après deux ans note deux
années en allemagne aussi de suite et
après la question c'est est ce que c'est
possible et comment c'est ça que vous
détiendront tout le monde dit ça serait
bien si on pouvait harmoniser mais les
écarts sont tellement grands dont on
commence alors d'abord pour pouvoir
harmoniser en avoir la priorité
l'objectif ce n'est pas le cas de
l'union européenne qui encore une fois a
choisi d'autres critères la concurrence
1 et le libre marché
le libre marché est un droit supérieur a
par exemple la charte des droits
fondamentaux
mais c'est vrai que c'était justement
inscrit la convergence c'est dans les
lobby principal du fse par exemple ces
convergences des niveaux de protection
du tout document pas comme ça c'est là
ça c'est la volonté cibler l'on pourrait
reprocher à l'heure à l'europe ne pas
avoir de vision est pas montré de
direction et du chemin de fer du
raccommodage n'empêche que dans les
fondamentaux des fondateurs de l'autre
encore une fois je vous prends l'exemple
de l'art et laval ça va être un peu
technique en 1996 mais il y en a eu
plein d'autres des comme ça hein c'est
une entreprise layton qui s'installe en
suède d'accord elle prend le droit du
travail le plus défavorable que fait
l'union européenne ya eu une plainte
la cour de justice européenne donne
droit d'embaucher sur les conditions de
travail du moins disant
donc ya pas d'harmonisation il ya au
contraire une façon de tirer vers le bas
le droit des salariés et non pas d'aller
vers le haut on n'a pas les outils
juridiques européens qui permet de cette
harmonisation ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut demain matin un smic européen pour
répondre à votre question on est les
différences sont très importantes
il faut progressivement tirer tout le
monde vers le haut ce que tout le monde
a les mêmes attentes
moi je crois que
les perspectives sont les mêmes parce
que la question c'est les peuples
européens et les choix d'orientation
mais vous voyez bien qu'aujourd'hui
l'union européenne elle fonctionne à
partir de la diplomatie entre les états
le peuple européen le poids du parlement
européen où on avance tout juste d'avoir
des élections même moment etc
il a du mal à s'exprimer et donc qu'il
faudrait des orientations qu'ils
puissent être tranché par les citoyens
de toute l'europe
d'accord juste une question que je suis
pas sûr d'avoir bien compris donc à
votre avis la solution pour résoudre ça
c'est une solution juridique politique
et gestion de droit ok très bien et les
soviétiques sociale qui explique
s'exprime dans après après dans le cas
du coup exactement mais un droit donc
par exemple unifier le droit du travail
sans une base une base réelle donc il
peut être une base évidemment économique
quelle est la solution à ça j'ai compris
bien comprendre comment vous vous
divisez la question économique de la
question sociale et la question sociale
liée à la question liée mais enfin tout
est nommé ainsi comment mais bien sûr la
dynamique sociale c'est ce que j'essaie
de dire depuis tout à l'heure la
dynamique sociale c'est à dire le fait
qu'on améliore les conditions de vie
qu'on puisse avoir un meilleur salaire
qu'on puisse avoir un emploi vous rendez
compte que en europe aujourd'hui le
chômage il est structurelle l'ordre de
10% de chômage
après ça dépend des pays il est
structurel donc il ya une harmonisation
et sur le chômage ont en effet diminué
en allemagne en angleterre les recettes
sont connus c'est qu'en fait on augmente
le nombre de jobs à 1 euro de gens qui
travaillent mais qui en fait sont en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
un allemand travaille justement sur leur
politique sociale alors que nous
en a justement il travaille pas dessus
parce qu'on amène juste actuellement il
ya 7 millions de travailleurs qui
travaillent avec un salaire de moins
d'un manque de 400 euros par du travail
alors qu'enfin du travail à 400 euros
moi j'appelle ça n'est ce qu'un agent je
n'avais pas fini sur le fait que en
allemagne également 15 15% de la
population qui vit en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté
après sur l'harmonisation des que les
peuples européens demandent des droits
supplémentaires on leur dit mais c'est
pas possible on n'est pas en état
fédéral et ans par contre quand il
s'agit de il s'agit d'harmoniser vers le
bas il ya les traités européens et c'est
là par contre c'est possible il ya pas
besoin d bon c'est pas possible
mais pour harmoniser vers lui juste en
fait actuellement en france par exemple
l'année dernière la cgt
elle a démontré qu'il ya des
travailleurs devient qui travaille pour
3 euros de l'heure la sncf par le biais
de la sous traitance par le biais de la
directive à ses cadets chronique
j'aimerais juste des petits exemples
c'est pas à la marge c'est le coeur du
problème c'est pas des petits exemples
qui déconne c'est le coeur du problème
la grèce c'est pas un petit exemple
c'est le coeur du problème
l'espagne regardez ce qui se passe en
espagne au début quand il ya eu les
entrants l'espagne l'italie la grèce
il ya eu un effort à l'époque moi je dit
pas il n'y a jamais rien qui est fait
d'ailleurs ces pays se sont un moment
donné développer cet effort-là n'ai pas
du tout fait pour les nouveaux entrants
absolument pas fait et surtout la
mécanique générale de choix économiques
de favoriser la logique de marché de
favoriser la finance retenez 4 milliards
pour l'emploi des jeunes 100 milliards
alors ce jour là dans les bons temps je
veux bien les dérives donné le congrès
de cession économie de la récession
économique in your gagnent d'abord sur
l'allemagne
myriem sur l'espagne et après on va
passer au sujet que oui à mon avis si on
tue pour l'allemagne il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ne peut s'entretenir par son
travail et c'est honteux
il faut faire quelque chose contre eux
mais je sais pas si le syndicat mais pas
de vivre forcément pour une bonne partie
des allemands tu dis oui mais je ne
crois que beaucoup d'allemands veut que
les gens ils peuvent vivre de son centre
apparaît donc tu dirais que l'europe
pourrait sauver l'allemagne
je ne sais pas les messieurs rilsan
différentes je ne crois pas que je
qu'une salaire minimum le smic que
puisse forcément résoudre tous les
problèmes
encore un exemple comment ça déconne
cette europe quand par exemple nous on
voulait un moment donné garder notre
poste comme service public
l'europe intervient dix est hors de
question c'est contraire à la libre
concurrence etc
vous devez ouvrir le capital de votre
service postal et c'est en lourd en
espagne quand il ya une remise en cause
qu'on entend la sur l'avortement le
droit à l'avortement votre charte des
droits fondamentaux cette europe si
favorable à l'égalité homme femme
on ne l'entend pas elle ne dit pas c'est
hors de question qu en espagne vous
remettiez en cause c'est à cause de pays
comme malte qui a mal ce qui s'est
carrément interdit mais c'est enfin je
veux dire ça c'est alors et pourquoi si
on l'avortement on n'est pas capable
d'imposer mais on est capable d'imposer
quand il s'agit de thé tricoter des
services
je suis totalement d'accord avec
clémentine parce qu'on sait centre
beaucoup si en effet économique on
oublie plutôt la politique sociale comme
entonné le aussi l'a remarqué et je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec jules on ne
peut pas imposer un système d smic qui
est bas dans les chemins de l'esclavagé
parce qu en espagne ce plan de les
systèmes qui sont en train de mettre en
place ces destins des minijupes alors
les jambons ils sont là tricard isation
à ces entreprises ils vont faire plus de
travail mais même s'ils font ça ils vont
pas arriver à vivre alors la solution
non plus 50 millions d'européens sont
sous-employés aujourd'hui c'est à dire
n'arrive pas à avoir un emploi pour
pouvoir vivre décemment vous rendez
compte ce que ça veut dire
c'est considérable c'est ça l'un des
problèmes numéro un aujourd'hui auxquels
nous devons faire face et l'union
européenne prend le chemin des banques
et pas celui des peuples
par ailleurs il ya quand même des
dispositifs des petites stratégies alors
après environ pourra juger de leur
efficacité ou pas mais et organes qui a
joué le tintin reporter dans cette
émission sa place c'était agréable ou
pas très agréable tu allé enquêter sur
stratégie sur la stratégie europe 2020
tu es alors convaincu pas vraiment on va
voir déjà son travail de recherche
jürgen 27 ans nous vient tout droit de
fribourg pour parfaire son français il
est assistant d'allemand dans un lycée
car joergen veut devenir prendre
d'espagnols et de français
rien de mieux donc un bel exercice de
journalistes
on reproche à l'europe de ne pas être
social et pourtant en juin 2010 il ya
donc trois ans et demi le conseil
européen a adopté une nouvelle stratégie
plutôt social nous mais europe 2020
europe 2020
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est moi
non un nouvelle directive de bruxelles
baba
direction la représentation parisienne
de la commission européenne ou your gun
à décrocher l'interview qui remet les
idées en classe
donc l'europe 2020 c'est quoi exactement
alors europe 2027 stratégies de sortie
de crise qui pour moi un des grands le
social l'environnemental et l'économique
ce qui est typiquement européen et c'est
une stratégie de long terme puisqu'elle
vise des objectifs à 2020
et c'est une stratégie qui vise aussi
des réformes structurelles robin 20 des
objectifs ambitieux qui concerne
l'emploi la recherche et l'innovation le
changement climatique et l'énergie
l'éducation et la lutte contre la
pauvreté
l'europe a beau être un continent riche
on estime à 80 5 millions le nombre de
pauvres sur 500 millions d'habitants en
2020 un affichage social louable oui
mais en pleine période de crise est-ce
bien réaliste
rencontre avec un européen convaincu
plus que sceptique mais pas dépenser
d'argent vous n'avez pas c'est ça le
problème majeur
2 europe 2020 ce qui est un peu étonnant
c'est que la communication de la
commission sur les stratégies la de fin
la crise financière les banques elles
étaient déjà connues
donc c'est un peu étonnant de voir cet
affichage le mesure extrêmement en effet
social ni la mise en alors que
normalement tout le monde savait déjà
dit dans les gouvernements
il n'y avait pas les moyens financiers
pour financer de telles dépenses
au fond la question qui se pose est ce
que la commission européenne a vraiment
les moyens pour mettre en oeuvre ses
objectifs ils composent le fameux monde
de la finance
joe hogan c'est bien de rappeler les
objectifs sociaux
c'est bien d'être ambitieux en la
matière c'est bien de faire ça sur dix
ans parce que les objectifs sociaux on
peux pas les atteindre
sur trois ans tout ça est bien mais
encore faut-il que la commission et du
pouvoir que des états et du pouvoir mais
depuis quinze ans à peu près le pouvoir
a progressivement basculer vers la
banque centrale européenne et depuis
cinq ans depuis la crise crise monétaire
tout le pouvoir malheureusement
appartient à la politique monétaire à
partir de là je pense que les objectifs
2020 sont plus tôt
on vient de voir ce sujet sur stratégie
europe 2020 la banque centrale
européenne depuis 15 ans
finalement c'est elle qui a la main sur
la politique monétaire donc les états et
la commission ben non mais surtout c'est
extrêmement de ça parce qu'en 2005 quand
on a eu le débat sur le traité
constitutionnel européen
alors que les français ont dit non le
traité a été adopté il s'est transformé
en traité de lisbonne est maintenant
2020 parce que c'est complètement la
suite de cette affaire-là europe 2020
j'ai bien j'étais à l'époque nous
exigions que la banque centrale
européenne ne soit pas indépendante
c'était l'une de nos revendications
phare constate aujourd'hui pas du tout
aujourd'hui lisa mais n'en a finalement
on n'a pas d'outils monétaires ils se
rendent compte qu'on n'a pas d'outils
monétaires mais en même temps la banque
centrale européenne elle fait le jeu des
marchés financiers et pour le coup c'est
ce qui fait que je vous signale que les
dernières années en dépit de la crise
les riches sont plus riches en europe et
les pauvres sont toujours on dit que tu
as très bien elle était à sa dernière
européen sur quatre qui est en situation
de pauvreté ou en risque de pauvreté
est-ce que du coup quand on regarde
comment fonctionne en gros ce genre de
dispositif ioana c'est quelque chose qui
te convaincre tu te dis finalement c'est
peu mais c'est déjà quelque chose où tu
as l'impression tout ça ne sert à rien
parce que c'est pas forcément pensé par
le bon cerveau le bon organes à mon avis
on doit pas mélanger la politique avec
le social l'économique
comment on peut trouver des fonds
comment on peut faire des contributions
sens si on n'a pas les sous derrière
alors si on économie qui nous soutient
derrière sur dans le
dans le reportage là un moment il ya des
intervenants qui diable comment on va
financer ça mais en fait il ya 200
milliards d'évasion fiscale par an qui
est organisée par l'union européenne en
france ça fait 80 milliards par an alors
comment on finance
mais en fait en taxant comment taxer
dans les années 70 tout simplement en
fait les libéraux ils ont organisé
depuis 40 ans la faillite des budgets
les budgets de l'état des budgets des
états par le biais des traités de libre
échange et par le biais d'un en
organisant les bateaux fiscale va
répondre à tout ça juste après la
question de jean sébastien faire un jour
de atlantico qui est notre partenaire et
qui voit lui à sa façon le verre à
moitié plein quand on parle
d'articulation entre politiques
économiques et politiques sociales en
quatre on a assisté ces dernières années
à l'incroyable élévation des niveaux de
vie dans les pays baltes en europe de
l'est ou plus largement dans le monde
grâce à l'extension de l'économie de
marché depuis 15 ans le nombre de gens
qui vivent avec moins d'un dollar par
jour à la même été divisé par deux bien
sûr que le capitalisme génère son lot de
problèmes
mais ce que vous ne croyez pas que
réclamer plus de législation sociale ça
n'est pas un peu mettre la charrue avant
les boeufs dans la mesure où il n'y a
pas de véritable progrès social sans
croissance économique atone et l'eau
qu'est ce que tu en penses toi de cette
articulation entre politiques
économiques politiques sociales
bien sûr la politique c'est ce qu'ils
organisent même l'économie et le social
donc à réalité le problème c'est
politique de gestion dans les états et
donc dans l'union européenne
et c'est pour cela même que l'économie
ne fonctionne pas mais moi je suis tout
à fait d'accord que pour avoir un europe
sociale une europe économique et donc le
problème à mon avis sa politique bien
sûr que didier a entonné on a les
moments un peu courte vue sur ce plateau
on oublie que la crise en fait elle est
venue par la finance par la dérégulation
en fait et donc oui il faut reposer des
cadres et l'économie pourquoi l'économie
va mal l'économie pas mal à cause des
politiques libérales et s'est même pas
moi
le social se s'en sortir sur l'économie
aujourd'hui plus la famille c'est le fmi
c'est quand même pas l'organe le plus
gauchiste je pense dans le monde même le
fmi a critiqué les politiques
d'austérité en europe
est ce qu'elle va nous faisons
maintenant les mêmes en fait on continue
dérégulé encore ou pas concrètement on
renforce les services publics en fait
l'économie ça se relance à l'économie ça
se relance par des politiques
industrielles ya pas de politique
industrielle au niveau européen par
exemple la porte l'industrie au niveau
repart bah non en fait c'est
complètement libéralisé donc tout le
monde fait tout et n'importe quoi quand
on produit du port en bretagne qui
l'envoyaient en allemagne pour être
conditionné qui revient en espagne pour
être vendus en espagne c'est n'importe
quoi en fait si tout devient absolument
protéger un cadre et cetera on veut être
la france et l'europe complètement
séparées dans le monde
et puis les autres continents les
américains les chinois et bien ils vont
bien soudé pour l'europe sociale ou pas
je suis absolument pour exemple c'est ça
qui va sauver l'europe selon vous c'est
la dernière se fait aujourd'hui à quoi
en fait changer la course dès la course
à la compétitivité internationale
elle nous met dans le mur et les crises
que nous traversons le montre soit il ya
un sursaut politique et social qui
passera par une mobilisation populaire
européenne et à ce moment là on peut
imaginer d'avoir un avenir de se
projeter de faire en sorte que
aujourd'hui les gens se disent pas que
demain nos enfants nos petits-enfants
vivent plus mal que nous donc c'est ce
sursaut politique et les social qui peut
remettre à l'endroit
ce que l'économie sociale de marché et
théorisée par les libéraux depuis en
gros les années 40 50 par un allemand
par exemple sur l'économie sociale de
marché comme l'a très bien dit le
philosophe foucault c'est pas une
économie de marché avec un peu de social
c'est l'idée que le libéralisme le
marché apportera le progrès social
la réalité elle est devant nos yeux ce
n'est pas le cas donc soit on remet à
l'endroit ce que le capitalisme et le
libéralisme mais à l'envers
soit je vous assure lamy risque de ne
pas être radiés moi je crois qu'il va y
avoir ce sursaut merci beaucoup que le
motive intox continue à parler de
l'avenir radieux de l'europe ce sera
dans le prochain numéro ou parlera
lorraine de la jeunesse donc voilà on se
retrouve le mois prochain pour une
nouvelle
génération europe va bien merci